thank you ben um and thanks for having
me
so this morning i'd like to talk about
python and i'd like to talk about why
python is for the curious
but first
i actually wasn't intending to i didn't
originally have this slide in here
but i wanted to fit in with
the crowd here so i'm going to go ahead
and do something that i i totally
despise
at least for myself
my name is john real
my the things i like to do
involve building tools for tool makers
so that involves meta programming
compiling parsing
things of that nature
and i've been using python since uh
python 1.3
i was in i was introduced to it in the
summer of 96 as an intern at nasa
since then i went on to use python at
lucent and more most recently at the uh
for the national institutes of health
uh and then somewhere in between there i
went ahead and
studied under david beasley at the
university of chicago uh earning a phd
in computer science
and uh
this this what we're actually seeing
here is a is an unfinished abandoned
building um this is actually a shout out
to my good friend dr andy terrell um
this is something i like to do uh
it has i think it actually comes from
a uh
a time in the in the in the late 90s
when it seemed like all you had to do
was was
start a project on sourceforge and then
dozens of developers would just flock to
you instantly and build out the rest of
your grand vision
so
this is perhaps my my claim to shame
right here this is something i've done
many times and uh but hopefully
i hope to make
make good on on some of the pro some of
the promises
of the past
now about this talk
i've never given a keynote um most of
the time
i'm up talking about something very spec
very specific very technical that i'm
excited about and i want to share with a
with a larger community
but i i reflect on what what kind of
keynotes really have an impact on me and
there are keynotes where you do the work
not the speaker
so
this is a bit of an experiment um
i've noticed that that a lot of talks
have kind of run short and how i
normally try to hedge against that is i
try to pace myself at about two minutes
a slide
but
my slide deck isn't isn't a technical
slide deck so this is actually the first
time i've kind of given a non-technical
slide deck
talk we'll see if i can
babble for more than two minutes of
slide
so let's let's start with a question are
you curious
i i
great
hand up already
now i want i actually chose this title
to be a little bit provocative because
you know curious can have some
mixed
kind of reactions are
are you strange are you odd um
i know my my uh former advisor dave
beasley really enjoys
kind of playing to this
this idea of being strange or odd but
that's not actually really the curiosity
i'm interested in talking to you about
today
although i would note that we're all
here on a perfectly beautiful weekend
talking about programming languages so
you're i think we all are a little bit
odd
okay so in continuing with the this this
kind of edginess um
could you be pi curious
um
i think it speaks that that speaks for
itself but but again this slide is
really more about the kind of the kind
of curiosity i'm talking about i'm
talking about the curiosity that that
george has
um
and then when i but but of course where
i actually get this image from is
actually an altoids ad
so let's
let's set the wayback machine to
1995 when altoids began this this uh
ad campaign where they had these these
green posters up and showing various p
things people
uh the one that had a greatest impact on
me showed a magician levitating
a tin of altoids in mid-air but i
couldn't actually find that on the
internet's
bad internets
so i had to settle for george which is
perfectly all right with me because
uh george
kind of reflects
what i think this is really about
that's beginner's mind
beginner's mind
if you if you'll take a moment with me
for with me
is about
having them having having a mind that is
not
burdened by the past or worrying about
the future
it just is
so to uh to quote uh flint sparks who's
uh i i saw speak recently uh
what he talked when he talks about zen
he says that really what he's always
really asking
is how simple can you make it
so how how simple can you make it
okay so now that we're all simple
and we we kind of arrived though at this
thing where we we have no we we're in
this stateless
moment of grace
but but we're still receiving all this
information
and
i think that one of the one of the
things that the brain does is just it
wants to know what's going on that's why
we have this this incredibly complex
piece of machinery that actually incurs
quite a bit of cost
biologically
to uh to have and maintain
so
we're simple
we're curious
this is the part where i really want
y'all to do the most work
what is it you are curious about
are you curious about the cosmos
are you curious about people
maybe your customers i i know a lot of
people
are are very curious about their
customers
are you curious about the the brain
are you curious about the bio biome
what is it you're curious about
how simple can you make it
okay great
so we have this
we actually are going to have to break
the rules a little bit we're going to
have to go back and say okay well there
are we we do have these patterns
we have these ways of dealing
with finding out about things
and it largely involves
a curious loop
so
we try to abandon our prejudices
from either our past experience or our
future expectations and observe the
world around us
and then just using those observations
we try to theorize or come up with some
idea of what's what's what may be going
on underneath the covers
based on those theories we can then
create predictions
and then we can test those predictions
in experiments which generate more
observations
and then we keep iterating in this loop
so how we find out about things
involves going through this loop
and how we find out about things
in on mass
means trying to tighten this loop and
make it as
fast as possible
great
so that's where people like me come in
i like i like automating things
and we can have have machines do this
for us
so what we're looking at here is a
microarray
where
you're doing
96 separate experiments all in one slide
and then your head but and it's all done
by machine by machines
machines
pick the reagents they drop them in the
in the reaction
tubules and then they evaluate whether
something interesting happened or not
based on your criteria for in for what
is interesting
okay wonderful but now
how do we tell them what to do
well
we use programming languages
but what do we want in a programming
language
we're talking about doing science here
we're talking about discovering things
that we're discovering more about what
things we're interested in
i'm lucky i i'm interested in computers
so
i i get to find out more about computers
and get to use all sorts of crazy
programming languages to learn more
about how i program
but
really at the end of the day what you
want in science is you want something
that's going to get out of the way and
just let you do the experiment
and do it fast and do it in parallel
so we need something that's easy to
learn
it's easy to read and write and and i
think that in part gets into this idea
of having something that fits in your
brain
without too much effort um
and and furthermore it should be easy to
use
um
the cost of of getting into the
environment
leveraging the environment should be as
minimal as possible
so i'm not willing to
at this point i'm not willing to
presuppose that that language is python
but i i do think i can present a little
bit of
evidence
uh perhaps puzzling evidence
that uh
python does
approximate something like like what we
really want
for doing science
so i was really excited when i was asked
to to give this talk
at the time i just received a
brand spanking new
issue of communications of the acm and i
saw that python that i saw this python
for beginners and i thought that was
that was great
i i
i've been using python for almost 20
years so if you do the math actually i'm
we're at about 19 years right now but
i'm rounding
um
but i i found it interesting when i
actually when you actually read this
article
that they're still
kind of echoing this this
argument i've heard from for many many
years
about how python is is is a very good
teaching language and what they're
really attacking is java because java
has had had
replaced uh had become the ap computer
science language and and so this was the
language that people who are taking uh
advanced placement
uh courses were coming into schools
already knowing
and and it was kind of assumed that this
was going to be the teaching the the
proper teaching language but uh so this
actually spends a lot of time talking
about how python is is better than java
for for teaching
but uh
another interesting point i'd like to
make here is that
uh i
i i this was something that was called
out in in the actual web article
um
but i i actually disagree with this
and i'm not saying that java is good for
writing small programs i'm actually
saying python's good for good good for
scale i think python scales in a way
that a lot of other languages that are
parsons parsimonious
it scales in a way the way that that
allows to create large systems i mean in
fact that that summer of 96 i wrote
something along the or on something on
the order of 5000 lines of python
and i was creating a tool for
doing doing unit test automation
that included
all sorts of stuff that hadn't hadn't
made it into the python standard library
at the time i was parsing
i was instrumenting
i was reflecting
and we'll get to that later
so is is python easy to fit in your head
i i think it is and i i think it remains
a very simple language um
the term in the uh
that has been thrown around the in the
community a lot
is its executable pseudo code
and i i think that does hold
and this also comes up in the acm
article
i think that
using white space to delimit blocks
it does does beginners a a service
and with the right editor
as a coder you don't miss the braces at
all
so it's easy to use
so here's
here's the first uh
eye chart i have
i'm not really out to prove anything by
this but
just the fact that
you have to write five lines
well i mean braces included
you have to write about three three real
lines of code in java just to say hello
world whereas in python you just have to
say print hello world
so we we
part of what makes this virtue it makes
python virtuous for doing science is
that it it tightens the loop between
between um hypothesis and experiment
so in in the java world we may observe
our program's behavior assuming we
already have well actually okay let's
let's start from from scratch we're
going to code first
but then we have to compile
and i don't want to i don't want to
actually
disparage compilation too much there are
there are roles that static typing and
compiled languages
uh fill
and and a language like python allows
you to actually leverage those things
later and again we'll talk about that
more but you do have this extra step
where you have an extra thing to enter
into the computer you have to say
compile my program and then you run it
and then you observe it and then you see
did i get what the results i expected
and then you go back to changing your
code
whereas
in python it can be as simple
as
coding
pressing return and then observing what
happens so we see this in ipython we see
this in pi
the python interpreter and that's
because in some sense python's curious
about you
it's running in this this it's in its
own curious loop
this is uh where we get this term repel
it expands to read evaluate print loop
so python's paying attention to us
as we're paying attention to our code
so i i do think python is easy to use
okay great i've just sold you right
no um
but
we gotta we gotta keep gotta get things
moving on here
so let's let's go bigger and faster
let's let's maybe take this idea of a
microarray where we're running multiple
experiments simultaneously and then
we're looking for interesting results
from those experiments and we're
collecting that information and then
considering the the consequences of
those experiments
so
one of the tools i've been working with
a lot uh recently is is spark
um
spark
in a nutshell
is is a driver for parallelizing code
across a distributed network
uh if you're not familiar with it
i i'm in
actually who here uh has used spark
okay
okay well so
spark comes from this
uh from the uh this java world
uh
predominantly seen as a way of of making
hadoop more performant
uh largely by hadoop was really
hadoop was really good is really good at
taking computationally bound problems
like scientific simulations and turning
them into i o bound uh making them i o
bounds problems
and spar spark kind of removes the pain
of that now
and again largely it's because it's not
taking the step of of being fault
tolerant and it's doing it it's keeping
more in memory and not serializing every
er er er
it's not checkpointing to to the disc
quite so much as hadoop does
so that's how we get
a driver and a lot of workers to do our
work in parallel for us
now
i
again apologies to andy terrell um
he said yesterday that uh whenever he
sees the work he sees word count he dies
a little bit
inside
yesterday if you missed it
but um
i've seen
a pro somewhere on the order of three
spark talks and and
the data brooks people
seem to really like this slide
because it shows how how
that that not only are they they're
running faster than hadoop but they're
running simpler
than hadoop the code to actually get the
to to to run and to run everything in
parallel is much more
compact um
and i i think that they want what they
really want to do there is is not focus
on the line count
so much as
what makes
their code so much more
succinct
and
what does that
i think is a co is a combination of two
things
you have
one you have to you have no types
in the sense that you don't have to type
in types you do have types but we'll get
to that in a second
but
it's hidden away from you if the compile
if if scala
or or and or python can figure out what
the types are
you don't have to you don't have to
enter them in but also it includes the
right abstractions and and what are the
right abstractions here
um
it's largely functional programming
so they have this idea
of of a map
phase where we get this is where we
actually get the term mapreduce or
which is the mr and
java mr
they have this map phase where they
apply
the same function over a large array of
data
and then they have a reduced phase where
again they're looking for interesting
things and they're reporting back to you
what the results of running all those
all those computations in parallel were
and and these are these are fundamental
concepts to functional programming and
they're included in python and they're
included in scala
let's talk about this a little bit i i
think that
scala is
is i i i i have to say that tentatively
i like scala
i think it has some problems that are
are related to its
being run on top of the java virtual
machine
um there are some things that they want
to do in terms of
pattern matching
which is something that python actually
doesn't do and it's something that i
would like to see
more of
but another big difference though is
that that scala is actually strongly
tight there there is a
even in its read evaluate print loop
it's it's it's running a little compiler
as is python actually python compiles to
the python virtual machine scala is
compiling to the java virtual machine
that's evaluating these virtual machines
um
now i wanted to give an example of of
how python's typing differs from scala
and i thought this would be a great
example
but uh
lo and behold
python doesn't do this what i thought
a scripty language should do and scala
actually does so
what i wanted to show here was that
in python
types are fundamentally just behaviors
and these are behaviors that can be
evaluated at runtime
and so when i i type 4 plus not the
string 99 at the interpreter it's going
to say it's going to immediately say oh
i can't do that but if i hide it behind
a function
it won't the python won't tell me about
that until i call that function
whereas on the other hand
uh scala will
because it's again doing this this kind
of type inference under the covers but
the thing that that
when i ran this experiment
i i was interested to find that that foo
on the on the right-hand side that's
scala
actually typed and and not only did it
type but it did the kind of it did it
did the uh the script what i call the
scripty thing in that it used plus to
figure out to say oh well i'm i one of
those things is a string one of those
things is an integer
i'm going to say
john wanted a string
and so i was expecting it to show the
definition of the function and python is
quiet about it and scala complains about
it but that's not actually what happened
so
there you go
now i'm actually not sure i explained
this this entirely
too well but uh if you have questions
about how behavioral typing differs from
from a from a type inference
i i'm more than happy to talk about that
ad nauseam
now i wanted to
pause them second here and and make a
point
because we're going to shift gears a
little bit here i'm i'm i'm going to
take off my my pseudoscientist hat
and i'm going to put on my my compiler
engineering hat
and i'm going to make a i'm going to
point
um
that hopefully ties what i do into the
data world i i haven't been doing data
science but i have been navigating data
for many many years and that's because
code is data
data may not necessarily be code but
code is data
and so how do we look at that data
python
python and java and and therefore scala
giving you these this this ability to do
reflection and introspection
and
what reflection is is basically we are
reflecting at the cert at the language
level what's going on inside the virtual
machine
you have a way of of querying your
virtual machine and say
what's up
um and introspection
gets into is just just just short of
meta programming in the sense that what
you're what you're having is a program
reason about itself using reflection so
reflection alone just tells me what's
going on and introspection is when my
program uses reflection
to figure out what's going on and adapt
appropriately
so i had this
image here of a
reflection but um i wanted to give you
pointers into where where where to get
started if you're interested in doing
this in python so things like like dir
which is just a way of inspecting name
spaces
the under under dict
everything in python is an object and
and more often than not
the properties of those objects are up
here in these dictionaries that you can
you can read and navigate through
the compiler itself is actually
reflected out to the surface language as
is the parser
and finally if you're really interested
in seeing what's going on under the
covers you can use this which is a
disassembler
and it takes you can you just hand it a
python function and it tells you what
byte codes are actually being used at
the virtual machine level
to run that to run that function
or that program
and so this this begins to get into
space of data exploration
i really
wish i had more time i think we all do
um
and what i mean by that is a time time
to explore
how to
represent information
in a succinct and useful way
so what i'm i'm showing here is
is really what i kind of think of of as
a culmination of reflection and
introspection this is an object browser
i'm sorry for the eye chart i was
looking for a better example but
um i couldn't i couldn't find it so i
just went with with the simple thing
that that popped up
but what we're looking at here is we're
looking at an object browser
in python that represents
objects in a namespace
as a tree that you can navigate through
and it this this is it's done lazily so
so you can navigate through this
information
without
worrying about it loading all your your
program state in at once
i wanted to maybe demonstrate some of
this stuff
so
let's
do a little demo here i wanted to look
at look at my my stuff
i'm gonna start up the python
interpreter
i'm gonna i'm gonna show you
what i'm talking about here
okay great so that's a dir that tells me
what the top level name space
what's going on there so let's we don't
have much going on in there
most of the funds and built-ins if
you're if you're curious
but let's let's import a module
let's import the parser
i like the parser i like writing parsers
uh
this one happens to be rather fast
but now we can ask
what's going on there
oh well we have we have stuff we have a
this ast type which is an abstract
syntax tree
it's a high level representation but
still machine readable um
version of your code
we have a probably an exception there a
type that probably that actually aliases
the asd type and then we have a few we
have a few
functions down below that mutate that
get us into the space of
taking code and getting abstract syntax
out
so let's go ahead and look at that
yup
this is an ipython
okay
again i apologize for
two things actually uh
the fir first the thing i wanted to show
is i actually wanted to show how easy it
was to get started writing one of these
things and i think that speaks to the
power of python's uh reflection and
introspection i think the the the hoops
that you have to jump through in java
are not only confusing because they're
munged with this this marketing concept
of java beans
but um
that those libraries aren't as
as has
predominantly uh aren't has much in the
forefront
and aren't aren't as loved as they are
in python
so let's look at the
part we've looked at parser module from
the command line let's do it graphically
so again if i was if i was writing this
i would actually make this a lot larger
so i could show you everything and
i seem to recall at some point there
being a uh
if you're not familiar with tikkenter
that's a a gui package one of the first
ones
that's shipped with python since i got
started with it
and um i seem to recall there being a
demo of using the grid layout to create
something not unlike this where but
instead of having a tree interface what
it did is it actually popped up a window
for each of your objects and then you
could click on a button and it would
open up another window that looked at
that object
and then with a few short modifications
one of probably one of the first things
i did as soon as i i started i
i got into this and my
my eyes were opened to this whole world
of introspection and data that i can
look at and navigate and browse
it was easy to modify it so that i only
opened up one window per object rather
than creating a window every time you
click the button it would say do i
already have a window up for this button
for this object and it would bring it to
the to the foreground
but this is a little bit more
sophisticated it uses a more
sophisticated uh widget tool set
uh specifically this is a using qt
via pi side
and again we can just
go through this stuff
ad nauseum
see if we can get to the
code
no i'm not going to do that okay fair
enough
but that's object browsing that's that's
a way of navigating data
it's well structured it's not it's not
semi-structured or unstructured so
my job's a little easier although i do
work with
with parsers so you do have concrete
syntax and that
that that is creating structure from uh
from unstructured input
so
great we have this ability to introspect
we have this way of reasoning about what
what there is
we have this way of running it of
creating more
very easily and we have have a way of
iterating quickly
on our experiments but
one of the great things about
about being a compiler
geek
is that
fractions of seconds still can still can
have a big impact on how long it takes a
piece of code to run when you're running
millions of computations in parallel
and so that's that's why i've spent a
lot of time
more recently working on the number
project
but there's there's a whole ecosystem of
tools out there
that once you have your code once you
have your initial experiment set up
you can say oh well i want to take this
and i want to make it i want to go large
with it and i want to go fast with it
so you can get your results faster
so here i just i just shout out a few
things that came off that came up to the
top of my head this is no way meant to
be comprehensive
but
numpy gets you a good boost when you're
doing numerical computations on vectors
or
multi-dimensional arrays
i think uh pi pi is is is interesting
and it's going to continue to be
interesting
uh particularly since uh it was
announced most recently at pycon that
they they have a story now for
including uh extension modules which was
really one of the re one of the things
that was keeping pi pi out of this this
numerical
land and actually it was that that
it was that uh
gulf
that i think led to the development of
the number project um cython
is
is a great tool
um it's a way of taking your existing
python code and then creating c code
from it
and then compiling that
with a little bit
excuse me with a little bit more
markup of your code you can actually
start
optionally typing bits of it and and
seeing in not not just speed up but very
impressive speed up
because
perhaps i should have mentioned this at
the beginning
why python gets you that that tight loop
of the read-a-val print is it's it's is
it's hitting a virtual machine it's not
actually creating
a a
machine code
and so it
embedded in that loop is yet another
loop of of interpretation and that that
the rule of thumb with interpretation
that's going to give you an order of
magnitude slowdown
so what we want to do is we want to take
these high-level languages and we want
to make them go as fast as the lower
level languages
and cython is is a good way of of
getting into that space without actually
having to write c
but if you're interested in writing c or
c plus plus we also have tools for
integrating those code bases into python
so we have cfi
we have swig
and i think that these were
more important in an earlier age when we
were still dealing with this idea of
legacy code
there was a lot less python out there in
the in the wild
in the beginning and and we had people
who had already invested in large c c
plus and fortran code bases
but at the same time we wanted to bring
in take those code bases and we wanted
to to to
add these abilities of reflection and
introspection
so that we could we could rapidly mock
up things
and again there's number so
where are we with that uh i'd like to
give a shout out to uh jake vanderblas
he uh
he wrote a blog post and i i'm using his
this graph from that post and he's
talking about
you know if i want to do a pairwise
distance between
two to uh two vectors
how long does that take
um so you have a python loop which
runs in
what appears to be a little over 10
seconds
and then you have numpy
which is once you use numpy
you can get that down to somewhere
around a tenth of a second
but then we start going into some other
stuff where you have scikit-learn where
they've gone and done some optimize
right wrote some optimized code that
goes faster and we have f to pi where
we're writing it in fortran and then
we're integrating it through
through uh scipy
we have sci pi itself uh actually i i
didn't read and read in depth enough
about what that's talking about but then
we have these two
at the over at the tail
we have a hundredths of a second with
cython in number
and i don't want to i don't want to
misrepresent this i i think cython has a
more complete coverage of the python
language than number does
but there are these silly cases where
you can quickly just take a take a
decorator add it to your code and make
it go faster i think that's a great
story
so
i think that's about as technical as i
want to get i i hopefully you i've
wetted your curiosity about numba
but i did want to i wanted to take a
moment to to speak to some stuff that
i've i heard
peter wang and andy terrell talk about
yesterday and so i was i was thinking
about this oh it's a we have this glue
language that allows us to glue together
other other code bases at the cabi level
um
and then uh but at the same time we like
to eat this
but we like to eat our own dog food i
like to eat my own dog food as a as a
tool writer
and so perhaps python is tasty tasty
glue
i'll leave it to you again as a
exercise as what the full implications
of that
but also
again with the tail of number what we're
really looking for is cost-free
abstraction so we want to we want to
take a half-baked sketch of an idea
and we want to push push peter's solve
button and we want to we want an optimal
data processing system i'll come out the
back end
we're not there yet
but we have ways of of approaching there
we have ways of of translating your
python code into c we have ways of
translating your code into assembly
language
and and we're constantly working on
on making it making the barrier of doing
something like this lower
without solving all the world's problems
all at once
i wanted to quickly mention that one of
the another thing you get with python is
is batteries
but where those batteries come from and
okay so batteries are included that was
that was an old
sales pitch for python um
and what that means is that
python has a lot of stuff in it already
in the standard library if you want to
if you want to write a
http server it's a one-liner
in fact you can do it from the command
line at this point
but where those batteries came from
is a large community that that's there
to that that's very friendly and likes
to share their code
and so i wanted to talk about these
these organizations enable python to
have these battery
to have batteries
but also they they give you
a
personalized way of of coding
that uh
languages that were written
in this in the 70s
actually have they probably have their
origins in the 50s
i you it's hard to talk to their their
language designers you can still go to
picon and walk up to guido and say hi
so what you i i there's still a kind of
a personalized feeling to that and if
if new people aren't getting that then
talk to me talk talk to the community
representatives because this is what
really we want to do is we want to reach
out we want to share our love
of software of good software tasteful
software
with the world
so
we're about done here
but i want to i want to go back to to
i'm hoping everyone was doing their
homework while i was babbling
and remind you what
what did you think of
what is it you're curious about
and then
i'll tell you what i'm curious about i'm
curious about
the second question and that is what
tools do you need to learn about what
you're curious about
so
that's it
um
i think i might have missed the point
where where oh no i did i got i got it
python python that it's the curiously
strong language and i mean that in the
sense that it was it's amazing what an
interpreted language can do
when when done well
so it's curiously strong language for
the curiously for the strongly curious
and uh i think that slide also
keeps the edge of being pi curious alive
um
thanks for listening to me and and thank
you for sharing for sharing your your
putting your thoughts out there into the
new sphere
whether whether you're going to share
them with people today or or in the
future
that's up to you but they're out there
and
we can we can we can explore them
thanks and i'll be happy to take
questions
you